what has been top of mind lately
uh i've built a serious meditation
practice and i
hesitate to talk about it because
i don't you know meditation
has also turned into this
sort of social game
so let me talk about meditation for a
bit let's let's stop the questions for a
moment because it's just confusing
everybody so please hold the questions
i'm not going to read them for a while
i'm going to talk about meditation
meditation is a difficult topic because
people use it to grandstand they used to
show off like oh i'm meditating how long
have you been meditating how good do you
feel what kind of meditation do you do
well my meditation is better than yours
so it turns into a competition
which is complete nonsense because
meditation is the uh the ultimate single
player activity
please hold the questions for now
meditation is the ultimate single player
activity
and it's not something you do for other
people you do it for yourself and you
don't do it
because you're trying to accomplish or
achieve something you do it because you
enjoy it
and when you do it because you enjoy it
then ironically you get the benefits out
of it
the thing that i learned about
meditation recently is at least from me
uh 20 minutes doesn't work you know we
we tell people go meditate for 20
minutes as a way of kind of easing them
into it the reality is you just have a
lot more junk in your head to clear out
then you can clear out in 20 minutes a
day
and so for for me it took a sustained
amount of time where for a month
straight
almost two months really i meditated for
an hour or more per day
and then only after that was my mind
clear enough
that i started enjoying the benefits and
the benefits are a little indescribable
but uh the closest analogy i can give is
it just makes me calmer happier
my breath is slower i almost feel like
my heart rate is slower
it also gives me all kinds of insights
and helps me solve problems that
normally i would just ignore and keep
sweeping under the rug and a really
giant pile builds up underneath that rug
but once you do clear your mind through
meditation or get it a lot clearer
it's just really enjoyable i
i sit down now and close my eyes for the
sheer pleasure of it
and that's a wonderful place to be but
it takes it takes work to get there
but i've been meditating on and off for
eight years and mostly failing and it
only started working well for me
recently once i started doing these
hour-long meditations so i would say
don't give up find the one that works
for you
i don't think it's about
forcibly clearing your mind
the reason when you sit down you close
your eyes that you have these
uncontrollable thoughts is
mostly because you have unresolved
issues these are these are all things
you need to sort through these are all
things that you need to think about
that you're not thinking about so it's
okay if you think about them because
you're going to sort them through and it
may take
days weeks months years to sort through
all of them but when you do the benefit
is a clear mind
i would recommend it
right at the beginning of the day
transcendental meditation never worked
for me
you know all the kundalini stuff all the
fancy stuff you don't need
the buddha supposedly became enlightened
just by concentrating on his breath
so if it was good enough for the buddha
it's probably good enough for you
and the system that i tried is basically
just sitting down for one hour every
morning one hour is the minimum less
than that i wouldn't bother
uh and just accepting and surrendering
whatever happens you basically just if
your mind runs let your mind run just
accept whatever it's gonna do
don't put any effort into it and don't
put any effort against it don't resist
it and don't push it either
i am not a world class meditator but all
i can tell you is that i've now managed
to get it to the level where
i don't think i'll ever stop and it's
made my life a lot better um someone
asked about sleepiness yeah the reason
to do it in the morning is so you don't
fall asleep um so you can lean your back
against something uh get comfortable and
still not fall asleep because otherwise
if you do it in the evening you either
have to be
incredibly
flexible and be able to sit straight
without leaning your back or you will
fall asleep
having a clear mind is wonderful
when your mind is clear
what remains is peace and um
if you take if you're in a peaceful
state and you're doing something it
almost turns into happiness it's like
free happiness without drugs without
alcohol
without even sort of external
stimulation
do i lay in a corpse pose no because i
would fall asleep and i think uh it for
me it works better when you're sitting
up straight they do say in meditation
you want your back straight there's
something to that
[Music]
[Music]
you